for months now people have been
protesting in Israel
Mass demonstrations
the biggest in the country's 75-year
history it's really scary it's scary to
think of this country possibly going
down the road to dictatorship or
theocracy or or some other implausible
idea of what might happen people are
angry at the government's radical plans
to overhaul the Supreme Court
many believe these plans will leave the
government without checks and balances
and will give too much power to the
current right-wing Coalition and they're
worried what do you fear is happening a
war
a war for democracy yes and it's not
just the size of the protests that's
concerning strikes are bringing the
country to a standstill and threatening
its National Security with military
reservists refusing to turn up for Duty
things that happened in the past few
days
are they've never happened before these
protests have divided Israelis deeply
over a question that's fundamental to
its democracy and what kind of country
it will become I'm Sally Lockwood and
this is the Sky News Daily
to help us understand what's going on
and just what's at stake I'm joined by
our Middle East correspondent Ali bunkel
well it kind of dates back in its
current form to pretty much the turn of
the year when a new government was
formed headed by benign Netanyahu who a
lot of people will know arguably one of
the world's best known politicians and
he became prime minister of Israel again
for the sixth time Israel's longest
serving leader this time though he is
the head of a coalition government that
contains some very extreme right-wing
individuals in that
now what they're trying to do is change
the way that the Supreme Court system
works and rebalance the power between
the courts and the knesset the Israeli
Parliament and that has caused a lot of
controversy in the country just explain
if you can Ali what the changes being
proposed are and why they're causing so
much anger well look firstly I can
understand that if the
Prospect of judicial reforms in a
foreign country makes you want to turn
off or fall asleep that is
understandable but actually when you
break it down what is happening here is
incredibly important in uh Democratic
country in the Middle East but there are
kind of three really big ones
the first is that they want the
government to have the power to overrule
the Supreme Court with just a majority
of one vote in the parliament the second
major reform would be that the
government would have a greater
influence over the appointment of any
new judge they're proposing that they
would increase the government
representation on the committee that
appoints judges okay so the government
would be able to effectively appoint the
judges who they might feel uh who are
more sympathetic to them and thirdly
ministers in government Ministries would
be allowed to appoint their own legal
advisors rather than having independent
legal advisors and these reforms are
also proposing to weaken the powers of
the Supreme Court as I understand it Ali
just explain to us why the Supreme Court
is so much of a lightning rod right now
Israel only has one chamber in the
parliament so where in Britain you've
got the House of Commons and the House
of Lords so you've kind of got that
upper chamber likewise in Washington
you've got House Representatives and
you've got the Senate that's not the
case in Israel there's just uh one house
in the Israeli Parliament and you've got
a president
who is largely ceremonial and so a lot
of people see the Supreme Court as being
the only area where you can have checks
and balances on what the government do
and that is why they are frightened that
if you
remove or weaken the power of the
Supreme Court you thus make the
government all-powerful
and is it right that some see this as a
battle for Israel's democracy
yeah very much so I mean if there are
two phrases or words that I've heard
over the last few months on the streets
of Israel it is
they're eroding our democracy and Benny
Netanyahu wants to turn into a dictator
now of course Netanyahu and his
government completely deny that they
actually believe that what they are
trying to do is they are trying to make
the country more democratic the right in
Israel are very frustrated they're happy
for many years very frustrated by the
power of the Supreme Court and the
Attorney General they think that the
courts are left-leaning institutions
they think that they are an unelected
elite and so what they believe they are
doing is bringing more power back to the
government back to the parliament uh and
they would argue that it is the
government who have been democratically
elected so it is therefore the
government who should be given the trust
and the power to make these decisions
we've seen the Supreme Court rule on
very contentious issues in Israel like
Jewish settlements in the West Bank
military service for orthodox Jews tell
us more about that it's a good way of
explaining the significance of the
Supreme Court's role
and it also ties in with the right wing
makeup of this this current government
so yeah to take this government as it is
at the moment you have a number of
figures in particular uh the Finance
Minister a man called bezel smotrich and
the security minister a man called
itamar bengavir and they are both pretty
widely considered here and
internationally as being on the extreme
right there's a lot smart rich people
might have seen in the news recently was
the one who said that hawara the
Palestinian town which has been the
scene of quite a lot of violence should
be wiped out
and both those men that I mentioned have
a history of wanting to
um increase settlement expansion in the
Palestinian West Bank but also
increase Israeli power over Palestinian
lives and so if they are successful in
getting these judicial reforms through
the liberal secular Israelis fear that
it will lead to Greater Israeli presence
in the West Bank and that then in turn
could uh lead to Greater violence
between Palestinians and Israelis a lot
of this tension has been mounting over
some time but what we're now seeing is
the most right-wing Administration in
Israeli history due to Benjamin
netanyahu's latest Coalition set up with
the conservative right wing and that is
why we're now seeing some of these
changes being proposed and consequently
the protests and reaction that we're
seeing as well within Israel is that
right indeed and because of the right
wing makeup of the Coalition a lot of
Israelis do not trust the government
Netanyahu himself
historically it's been quite a popular
politician I mean that is why he's
managed to become Prime Minister six
times and Israel's longest serving
leader I mean you don't have that claim
to fame if you've not been popular down
the years
but people are now starting to change
their opinions towards benign Netanyahu
he has been seen to be beholden to the
far right in his Coalition and for a
prime minister who has got so much
experience at navigating the choppy
political Waters in Israel he really
seems as though he's
boxed himself into a corner on this one
and there's another thing to add about
Benjamin Netanyahu in all of this he is
currently on trial for charges of Fraud
and Corruption which I should say he
completely denies and there is a very
wide school of thought here in Israel
that the reason that he wants to push
through these judicial reforms is to
ultimately
remove himself from that court process
and so they see him as being
self-interested and just wanting greater
power and doing this just to save
himself further days in court but as you
say he does strenuously deny those
charges I guess the big question is Ali
what Now by pausing these judicial
reforms in the wake of all these
protests
is that going to do enough to calm
tensions or is that just kicking the can
down the road
it is kicking the can down the road I
think two things will happen
firstly it presents a window for
dialogue and potential compromise
Netanyahu says that he's wanted dialogue
with the opposition all along
the opposition though have remained
United despite part of political
differences and have always said we will
not enter into any dialogue until you
pause these reforms and then we can sit
around a table and we can try and come
to some sort of agreement well that
moment is now so there is time now for
the opposition for the government and
I'm sure there'll be a role to be played
by the Israeli president to try and find
some compromise Some Way Forward which
satisfies both sides
however the protesters who have a major
voice in all of this as we've seen think
that this is a political sleight of hand
by Benjamin Netanyahu and they believe
that all he's doing is he's trying to
calm the situation take the sting out of
the protests and in a few weeks time he
will just start all over again to try
and push these reforms through and it's
because of that that they will not stop
protesting I've I've spoken to the
protest leaders many times over the last
24 hours or so they will not stop
protesting I don't think we will see
what we saw on Monday when the country
just came to a shutdown it was
extraordinary remind listeners what
happened on on Monday early it was
almost a general strike in Israel wasn't
it it was a general strike uh it was
because on Sunday night
who fired his defense minister a guy
called yov Gallant for speaking out and
asking for a pause in the reforms
because he was seeing what the protests
were doing to the operational Readiness
to the capabilities of the Israeli
military and the defense minister felt
he could take no more and had to speak
out Netanyahu didn't listen he fired him
and almost immediately and that is no
exaggeration like within minutes people
started coming out of their homes on a
Sunday night onto the streets of Israel
Tel Aviv Jerusalem and other towns and
cities up and down the country and they
stayed there throughout Monday and it
built and it built and Ben gurin airport
had to pause flights because staff
walked out you had a number of the
largest trade unions telling their staff
to walk out on strike that meant that
Israeli diplomatic missions embassies
Around the World closed their doors
major shopping balls closed their doors
the 200 or so McDonald's branches up and
down the country stop serving food you
know it it just became this widespread
general strike and the pressure came too
much on Netanyahu he locked himself away
throughout the day in discussions with
his Coalition members trying to make
sure that this was not going to result
in the collapse of his government and he
eventually came out on National
Television uh late into the evening on
Monday and announced that he would pause
the reforms
[Music]
it's not just the size of these protests
that you say will probably not stop it's
also who is protesting you know Israel's
Defense Force reservist for example how
concerning is this for Israel when it
comes to their ability to protect
themselves
hugely concerning one of the fabled
bomber squadrons that conducts missions
you know quite regularly today uh over
Syria against Iranian Targets in
particular operating in Syria many of
their pilots went out on strike which of
course
um reduced the capability of that that
Squadron uh you had Intelligence
Officers going out on strike you had
infantry officers going out on strike it
was across the board and I think that it
took the government in particular
Netanyahu really by surprise the other
area that is taking the government by
surprise is a is another area that is
core to the Israeli uh society and the
way that the military is and that is the
tech sector Israel is very proud of its
uh Tech sector there's a lot of
technology that we use these days that
was developed here things like the Waze
app for example and money was starting
to seep out of that they said look we're
not going to spend any of that money in
Israel whilst this goes on whether we're
going to hire any jobs there we're not
going to put any investment there
because we're worried about what the
judicial reforms mean you know you're
seeing the economic impact with tech
leaders saying that they'd pull out of
the country you're saying you're seeing
that the security impact in terms of
Defense Force reservists striking but at
the center of all this it's the concern
about Israeli democracy Ali
it is and that is why it is widespread
and I think the power of the protests
has lied in two key areas firstly the
fact that it is across the board they
can't be dismissed as
a small minority group on the left
actually Netanyahu described them as an
ex an extreme minority uh they're not
you know as I said you've got the tech
sector you've got the military you've
got academics you've got doctors you've
got lawyers you know it is across the
board it is also across the board when
it comes to age you've got young you've
got old and it is across the board as
well when you come to religion you've
got the religious and you've got the
secular there and that gave the protests
an awful lot of power the second thing
that gave the protest power is they've
remained really very peaceful by and
large there have been arrests there have
been occasions when the police have had
to use water cannon or tear gas but
that's been pretty minimal and I think
that has allowed the protesters uh to
keep uh the upper ground the moral High
Ground in all of this and on top of all
these Mass protests and Strikes within
Israel Ali we've also seen growing
tensions and violence between the
Israeli military and Palestinians in
recent months is there a connection
between all the this
I wouldn't necessarily draw a direct
connection but everything at the same
time here is linked it is a very small
country in many ways and so what goes on
in one place has an enormous impact
quite often in what goes on elsewhere we
have seen very very worrying Rising
tensions in the West Bank there are
really big fears that the violence could
spiral out of control
um already this year more than 80
Palestinians have been killed 12
Israelis have lost their lives in Terror
attacks the Israeli military are
carrying out regular raids into West
Bank towns and Villages
often those lead to very violent clashes
gun fights civilians have lost their
lives as well and so you have a
government fighting battles on two
fronts fronts at the moment the
Judiciary reforms and the protests that
accompany those but also the security
matters in the West Bank
what do you see Happening Now Ali I
think we're in very dangerous territory
there has already been warnings of the
potential of a civil war here and so if
a compromised path is not established
then the protesters would go back on the
streets Netanyahu will have made it very
clear that he is not going to budge and
then you have a standoff whether or not
to be a civil war my my personal feeling
is is that I can't see that happening
because at the end of the day I think
Israelis will pull together for the
greater good of the country whatever on
however that might present itself
but I do think when you hear
senior politicians warn of a civil war
it does make you realize how serious
this could get and I think we could get
to the point if the government refuses
to give any ground and wants to continue
to push through its reforms I think we
very really could get to a point where
the protests turn more violent and then
who knows where it goes from there my
thanks to Ali bunkel and to you for
listening to the Sky News Daily with me
Sally Lockwood this episode was produced
by Emma Ray Woodhouse our editor is
Philly Beaumont
yeah foreign